can we give janet yellen some love here
i've been with jenna's been waiting
let's let's give janet the deal and
somehow janet yellen love you yearns
of a possible october default on u.s
debt swollen
by the pandemic this is a new york times
story the united states could default on
its debt sometime in october if congress
does not take action to raise or suspend
the debt limit treasury secretary janet
elliott warned on wednesday the
extraordinary measures that the treasury
department has been employing to finance
the government on a temporary basis
since august 1st will be exhausted next
month
yellen said in a letter to lawmakers
once all available measures and cash on
hand are fully exhausted the united
states of america would be unable to
meet its obligations for the first time
in our history i like that
yellen said that a default would cause
irrepar irreparable harm to the us
economy and to global financial markets
and that even coming close to defaulting
could be harmful
maybe that's not a bad idea for us to
actually see how fake of an economy we
have maybe let's find out for about 30
days how fake our economy is maybe let's
find out what's really going on listen
this is coming from a guy i just bought
a big house can you imagine my property
value drops 25 if that's the number fine
do it
let's find out how fake the current
economy earned it down let's not do that
no no no but wait a minute why not how
long can we manage fake you realize
we're funding this fake
we're funding all this fakeness
we're funding all of this fakeness
interest rates staying low for as long
as they have first time in the history
of america it's funding fake economy in
the words of richard nixon they're all
kenzians now there is nothing good about
what they're doing right now it's just
temporary catastrophe because they're
worried about whether they're gonna get
re-elected or not and by the way that's
not a left or right thing that's both of
them
neither one of them wants the economy to
get back to being real because that
president will be a one-term president
but american voters have to be thinking
about what's more important a fake
economy that eventually the whole thing
explodes or let's kind of settle down a
little bit let me ask you pat every year
there's this like raise the debt ceiling
we're going to default like every every
year every year it happens
what's different this time around
is there something different obviously
with the printing of money five trillion
over the last two years
is it different is it the same oh my god
this guy's falling in there
at the last second the superhero comes
in and saves it
what's different this time what's
different is they
they they want to pass a three and a
half million dollar budget by september
27th if you want to ask that let me go
to page go to page uh joe manchin you
brought this up let's just read what joe
has to say about this so let's see joe
manchin says there's no way to pass a
three and a half billion dollar budget
trillion dollar budget bill by september
27 a cnbc story notice what she said
she said what by the end of the month is
what she said right by the end of the
month we have to figure out a way to
address this by the end of the month
right exhaust it next month so now joe
says
no way we're going to pass this three
and a half trillion dollars
uh adding that there's no way to meet
the september 27 deadline set by
democrats mansions comments come as
lawmakers work to prove the measures
which would invest in climate policy and
expand social programs including child
care and health care without the support
of republicans who have opposed the
proposed tax increases to fund it we've
already put out 5.4 trillion dollars and
we've tried to help americans in every
possible way we can and a lot of help
that we've put out there is still there
and it's still going to run clear until
next year 2022 so what's the urgency
what's the urgency that we have it's not
the same urgency that we had with the
american rescue plan he said this is
mentioned saying this so
you asked the question mansion just
answered it for you they're trying to
push to get that three and a half
trillion dollars
look look at what they've done look at
what they've done they shut your
business down they bankrupted you for 18
months now they're going to raise your
taxes higher than they've ever raised
them until everybody in america is
paying 50 percent of their freaking
money to things that they don't want and
they're devaluing the dollars that you
already have so not only did they shut
you down and give all your money to
their donors but now they're gonna raise
your taxes so what little hope you have
left disappears and your money save that
money is gonna be half what is the value
of the dollar in ten years
this is insane what we're doing is pure
insanity this is like it this is a theft
the likes of which this is a wealth
transfer likes it with we've never seen
in our lifetime
like i can't even believe people are
going along with this
like think of those three things these
are incontrovertible facts again this is
not left this is not right this is
reality both sides are doing that they
shut you down it's not a left or right
they devalued your dollar and now
they're stealing your future earnings
but it's but it's it's guys there's
nothing worse than fake success because
the fall is
unbelievably painful
you know what's fake success like you
know how the boxer you know the scene
where where rocky is like
you know when mickey says you know you
dude this guy's gonna hurt you when he's
facing against who the the the clever
lank right like this guy's gonna just do
this you're not at this guy what are you
talking about i can beat him he says no
you can't you're not ready for it
because sometimes behind like boxers
what do they do they only put people in
front of their boxer because they're
trying to build the guys confident but
the trainer kind of knows this guy
cannot fight with the number one number
two or number three you ain't that good
i'm just trying to protect you right to
kind of get a test for it we've been
faking it as if america's economy is
bulletproof it's not
it's not they have to kind of bring you
back and realize like do you realize how
many things that are common sense we're
starting to question whether we're right
or wrong
let me say that one more time how many
things that are common sense what's
common sense
they don't go into debt more than you
can afford but we're like no but we
should because that's what we're
supposed to do
uh let's keep printing money and it's
gonna
decrease the value of u.s dollar not
necessarily
not necessarily because people say it's
not going to
tell me a time in history that anything
you over printed the value of that one
up tell me show your work one time but
but the point is we as the populace are
questioning ourselves like the whole
gaslighting deal we're getting destroyed
with gas lighting right now you're
starting to question like normal things
am i really that dumb
am i like maybe i'm not as smart as
these guys at this level maybe yellen is
at a whole different level than i am
maybe i don't have the intelligence of
what these guys are maybe i should just
shut up and say well these guys know
what they're doing and i don't you're
right let's keep printing money you're
right let's keep doing this you're right
let's keep doing that
no i think i think common sense people
need to go back to common sense this is
not tech you know
technical math this is common sense math
it's not it's not extremely technical if
you keep printing anything the value
goes down period it just does and they
keep doing it anyways so what do you
think they should actually do zero
should they is there is there a number
that they should
come up with is it one trillion did you
ever quit that you were cold turkey
what did you ever quit that you were
cold turkey on did you ever put anything
cold turkey like you're like i was
smoking weed and then all of a sudden
next i'm like i'm done chewing the bag i
was drinking alcohol the next acid i'm
done drinking alcohol luckily i've never
had those problems but i know you
stopped drinking hard liquor yeah but
you in the background went cold turkey
yeah do culture how did you do alcohol
wait a minute like did you go cold
turkey with alcohol hard alcohol yeah
yeah yeah but i still but i
i used to drink a lot now i'm down to
like you know a couple beers on on a
friday that's pretty much okay but
that's not cold turkey though no no i'm
talking the only thing i ever did cold
turkey was chew in the background okay
so the point i'm trying to make to you
is you don't have to go cold turkey with
this
you don't have to go from one percent to
six percent no you put a plan and you
manage expectation every quarter the
interest rates are going up a quarter of
a percent the next four years
i just want people to realize so guess
what you do if you say every quarter the
rates are going up a quarter of a
percent the populace is sitting there
saying what fine it's good because it's
getting me to be prepared that in the
next four years i can't be going around
thinking i'm big shouting anything no
this is kind of what it's looking like
every quarter every quarter we're going
through this every quarter we're going
through this
rather than this
yeah we still can't i know we still
can't we still can't manage expectations
so should we change the election cycles
then instead of two
four year terms should a president be a
one eight year term should we get rid of
reelections the only way to do that is
with foresight i mean so much of what
we're doing now is dependent on election
cycles
and i think that that's you know kind of
i'm not a fan of the elections i'm not
term limits i i think is a little bit
more realistic than elections voting is
supposed to be term limits i mean we are
supposed to be the term limits you know
so sometimes look you could put you know
but the federal anybody where pelosi is
they're gonna win but the federal
reserve
is its own stand alone
so to me federal it's not even a
government agency i know it's not the
federal reserve needs to be standalone
and make its own here's what we're doing
over the next eight years so the voter
like let's just say
if the president's running and the
president says the following says listen
guys i don't control federal reserve
that's not my job so whatever happened
with the interest rates i know it kind
of affected the market i can't change
that because it's out of my jurisdiction
the federal reserve has one job in place
is to make sure we become as close to as
debt-free as possible and it maintains
the economy in a proper way that keeps
growing right and healthy employment as
well yeah employment as well so so i
think if they set that part aside to say
that this is its own person that gets
voted by the by the people you know
somebody that we even like for federal
because it's a big big decision maker
maybe even more powerful than a
president sometimes right so if we did
that and a person said
yeah president biden president trump you
don't have any
jurisdiction over me on what we do here
you can give feedback sure but this is
what we're doing the interest rates is
going to go up a quarter of a percent
every quarter over the next eight years
and we're gonna try to hover around
three percent whatever pick a number i'm
just making up a number there for you
but staying the way we are right one
more month
one more quarter yeah one more question
this is not an effective thing it's zero
we can't maintain no way no way but i do
want to i know why is that important by
the way why is it so important to get
them to a normal level how do you pay
off debt in your personal life
do you do you all of a sudden what do
you mean you just raise your debt
ceiling you can't do that though
you can't do that do you understand what
you just said like it's a joke but you
can't do that right hey can we raise my
credit card limit i'm in debt forty
thousand like if you call actually think
about it you got a crew you got you got
a credit card with ten thousand dollars
you're at ten thousand dollars you call
mbna you call amex you call this
government say hey i know i'm in that
ten thousand dollars my credit card
limit is ten thousand do you guys mind
to helping my credit score increase my
limit to twenty thousand dollars because
it's hurting my credit score yeah you
tell me what discover amex or visa
mastercard is going to tell you they're
going to say
i'm sorry what somebody should actually
do this and say but presidents do that
why can't i do that
that's raising the the maximum capacity
of the debt i'm talking about you're
talking about raising the interest rates
from 0 to point two five
to a hundred points or whatever it is
well why is it in one direction
why is it important
to raise them if you if you from zero
basement is flooded if your basement is
flooded it doesn't matter how many
additions you put on to the house the
basement's still flooded that's what
he's saying no matter how many times you
you address the the debt right you're
not addressing the deficit you you have
to get rid of the water that's flooding
your basement putting an addition on the
house doesn't do it i'm a thousand
percent with you on the on why you don't
want debt in your life i'm with you but
why is raising the interest rates
important meaning why do you want to get
to three percent yeah as an example look
when i understand that concept about not
having debt i get it in terms of the
interest rate when the interest rates
are low
anything that you finance the value of
it is higher because it's free money
right like right now everybody who's a
businessman who's running a company if
they can get a line from the government
for a billion dollar debt go get it
everyone's doing it leverage through
this yeah if you can get 100 same thing
at one percent it's nothing you're
paying nothing there's one thing you do
percentage money is so cheap today go
get it so this is why you can qualify
you know how you see certainly when the
rich can qualify right people that are
buying one house two house three house
four house five hours six on seven eight
nine dude this guy you got six ferraris
in a garage got nine lamb i remember a
guy back in 2005 he had four different
rolls royce same exact phantom parked
outside of his house everybody would
just go to this guy said like this guy's
freaking
rich as hell but no income no asset
anything you can finance for nothing the
moment 08 came around the market tank 38
percent not only did he lose all his
rolls royce he lost the two houses he
owed the government five million dollars
and he didn't know how to pay for it but
that needed to be filtered out of course
so the interest rates makes everything
eventually be
worth what it's worth a guy buys a house
right down here i looked at this house
we went and looked at it
we walked left the house it looked like
a 50 shades of grey house the guy ends
up buying it for 17 million
the next month after he buys it for 17
million
he puts it on the market for 31 million
dollars he just raised the price to 32
million dollars someone's about to buy
that thing for 30 million
in four months he bought it from 17
million it's going to sell for 30
million that doesn't make any sense
good purchase right there he didn't do
nothing to the house the house like
nothing to the house here's ultimately
my question and i want to get your
advice on this you remember back in the
80s um
interest rates on mortgages were like 12
yeah let me say that again interest
rates on mortgages were like 12 the
great jimmy carter everything was going
insane well even when reagan was there
it was all throughout the 80s he lowered
it it started to lower it started to
taper off but even in all even up until
the 90s it was at double digits almost
the point is this comes from the
community reinvestment i said up until
the 90s all throughout the 80s but the
point is this what's the sweet spot
you're saying use three percent as an
example
obviously zero is no good and obviously
you don't wanna be spending ten percent
on your mortgage payment uh on your
interest on your is there a number that
you have in mind is what i'm asking you
said
three percent is exactly no man like i
mean it's like asking how much break do
you need it's like well if you're going
25 miles an hour you need this much
break if you're going 95 miles an hour
you need a little more break you know
i mean it it's it's subject to the times
double digit wasn't in the 90s it was
84. i said into through the 80s up until
90. but then carter's last era was last
year was 16.39 crazy and we got elected
it was five point five four so he took
it from five dollars prime rate
he took he took the average yield from
5.54 to sixteen percent cds were paying
14 15 16 at the time by the way
everything that is 16 yeah that's what
i'm saying it's insane
but every the conversation i'm having
right now
this is the type of stuff that they
don't teach you in school this is what i
talk about all the time but
you talked about getting books getting
books on negotiations getting books on
sales getting big books on how money
works interest rates is our major part
of it i think you're not i think what
you're teaching is necessary i think
that concept is necessary but even this
is stuff that this is macroeconomics
it's the us gdp but it's not though but
it's not though just go to that visual
just think about it
like i said what's tall you said i don't
think six is tall six times i said why
do you think that because any
everything's always i'm not good enough
we always have that mentality i'm not
rich enough i'm not successful i'm not
tall enough i'm not strong enough it's
always the guy that's a little bit more
stronger that's strong right we're
always kind of think that way and then
internally we're confident but i don't
know maybe about this
it's not if you called your credit card
company
and you said i got ten thousand dollar
credit card with ten thousand i max it
out can you give me another limit for 10
grand what's the credit card company
gonna say to you
actually tell me what you think they're
gonna say to you they're gonna say
what the hell is wrong with you
credit card companies will probably say
sure buddy keep charging you will not do
that no to give you additional 10.
you give an additional intent to
somebody that doesn't know how to handle
their money you don't do that you know
when you know what c's might have given
you another 10. you know what points you
know when i got the price you know when
i got a ton of credit
is when i don't need any credit yeah
exactly we're going to raise your limit
to a hundred thousand cool
but you know what's bro i'm going to
raise it to 200 000 for what though
let's go i'll take it but you have to
spend ten thousand dollars a month yeah
but but the point i'm trying to make to
you is this stuff is not as complicated
what the politicians are famous for
doing is to convince the populists that
they're smarter than them and let them
make the decision for them no no these
are regular people just like you okay
these are regular people they just
decided to go get their job to be a
politician and they're on tv and just
because you're on tv people think you're
smart because you don't agree with you
that we need to stop glorifying
politicians left and right if i could
for a second all right because we we
kind of brushed over this but i think
this is very important for people to
hear
they're they're trying they are
basically with this re-infrastructure
act trying to make an effective 50 tax
rate for all americans essentially is
what they're going for okay so just
understand people listening at home okay
especially my blue collar people you're
sitting in traffic an hour to get to
work you don't get paid for that all
right then you're going to go to work
half of you work a job you don't want to
work in but you need to because you're
you're you you have responsibilities
you're a dutiful person so eight hours
each day you do that then you sit in
traffic another hour home 10 hours of
your day then you see your family for
three hours you go to sleep okay so 10
hours away from your family doing a job
you probably don't want to do sit in the
traffic you don't want to sit in
under this you've got to understand what
taxes are that means you will not earn a
dollar you will not actually earn any
money for you or your family not january
not february not march not april not may
not june
until july first you are a wage slave to
the government to the government that
just left 85 billion dollars worth of
stuff behind in for the taliban that's
how much they care about the hours of
your life that's how much they care
about your money your tax dollars that
they're gonna raise that they just left
85 billion dollars for the taliban to
use as as christmas toys okay and now
they want more of your life stop looking
at it as money folks i beg you stop
looking at it as money this is hours of
your life that they are stealing from
you yeah i mean that's a
that brings it back to a very uh good
visual for people to be thinking about
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]